(audience applauds)
- My God.
- So do y'all know each other or you just,
y'all saw each other, right?
- I ran into him at TomTom,
- Yeah.
- Not long ago.
- She came to my party.
She showed up.
- Yeah.
- It was very lovely.
- That place is good.
- It is really good.
- We actually raided your party.
- No you did not raid-
- We weren't supposed to be there.
- I begged her to come to my party,
and she came by for one drink.
It was such a treat.
Thank you for that.
- I hear I owe your friend,
this is a funny story.
Your friend's name is Braeden, right?
That I owe an apology.
- Yeah, Braeden Lemasters.
He's an actor, he is in
the band "The Wallows".
I ditched, I think it might have been
his 21st birthday party
to go to your concert.
- This is a horrible story.
- I know, I know.
I invited a bunch of friends
that had never met him,
and I have these texts
from, I think 2019 saying,
I'm so sorry, I have to bail
on you, it's Kelly Clarkson.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience claps)
Babe, it's Kelly Clarkson.
- [Kelly] He's gonna be truly confused
if we show up without you.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Lukas] Some people wait a lifetime
for a moment like this.
(Kelly laughing)
- I love that you invited people
to your friend's party
that he doesn't know.
And then you were like dooses.
- I mean, listen.
- [Kelly] That's incredibly funny.
- Yeah, I did it for you.
- Still friends?
- Still friends, I love him.
- Still friends, yeah.
- I want to give a public
apology to Braeden Lemasters.
- I am sorry as well.
- From Kelly Clarkson
and myself, I am sorry.
- How dare I plan a tour on that day.
- Damn you, damn you.
- That's just hilarious.
That story is like, is that real?
- [Lukas] Oh, it's real.
- My friends would never
let me live that down.
So you've got part two of the
new season of you on Netflix.
So can you tell us about it?
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] What's going on?
- Well, part two is, it's
full of more surprises.
Everyone's a suspect.
It's a kind of a Whodunit
murder mystery this season.
Agatha Christie inspired so-
- Love her.
- It's, yeah, it's amazing.
Everyone's a suspect,
so you're gonna have to
find out what happens.
It's pretty juicy.
- So speaking of finding out what happens.
- Yeah.
- I hear these, is this
the kind of show where
you don't get the script
to like right before?
Like 'cause you don't
know if you're gonna die.
- Yeah.
- Because I feel like a lot of people die.
- I'm waiting to die every episode.
I'm like, when is Joe
putting me in his cage?
Lock me up, get me in there.
No, we don't know.
So every, and we didn't know
who the murderer is this season.
So every episode we're just
suspicious of everyone and ourselves.
- That's kind of fun.
- It's fun.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it is fun.
- I don't like a spoiler alert, so yeah.
- Me neither.
- Yeah.
- My mom does.
Do you know people that read?
My mom will read the
end of the book first.
- I like spoilers.
- You like spoilers?
- [Kelly] What the hell
is wrong with y'all?
- I know, I know, I know.
- I'm like, I don't want a spoiler alert.
I wanna go for the ride.
- It's the type of show I
watch while getting a massage.
- [Kelly] Yeah, (laughing)
- It is?
- It is.
- I was gonna say, have you seen "You"?
You watch-
- All seasons, yep.
- Yeah.
- With John.
He loves it too.
- [Kelly] I love that you're,
while you're getting a facial and massage,
you're watching death, it's amazing.
- [Lukas] It's soothing.
- It's soothing?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
So yeah, so I'll buy into that.
So you also wrote a comedy,
which I think is awesome.
A writer as well.
So it's called "Down Low".
What's it about?
- It's called "Down Low".
It's about a masseuse.
I'm going back with, wait,
Chrissy gonna love this movie.
Yeah, he's a masseuse sex worker,
and he spends a night
with a repressed man,
and the movie takes place
within eight hours of a night.
It's a revolving door
with the Zachary Quinto,
Simon Rex, Judith Light,
Audra McDonald, and myself.
- [Kelly] Wow.
Great cast.
(audience applauds)
- Really good, I dunno how I did it.
- So it's all, so it
pretty much takes place
in like one, I mean, eight hours.
You can't be that many places?
- Oh no, it's one house, the whole movie.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- That's cool.
- We needed a movie that made
sense during the pandemic
that was easy to shoot,
that a couple actors,
one location and it was
it was a lot of work,
but I'm super proud of it.
- [Kelly] All right.
Well you've had some nude scenes.
So why I bring this up is
I often wonder for actors,
like, what does your mama, like,
is she like watching it or?
- [Chris] First of all, I just wanna say
my mom said no one would
recognize me with my clothes on.
And I just wanna say I feel like people
recognize me when I
walked out a little bit.
But yeah, my mom, you
know, my mom's the coolest.
She says I have the cutest
butt that I should just-
- [Kelly] Yeah
- I should show it off.
- Yeah.
- You know.
- [Kelly] I like that.
- I gotta show it off while I can.
I can't give this away.
- Yeah, I can't give (laughs)
- I can't give this away.
- I just love it.
I always wonder, I'm like,
doesn't ever bother me
but I'm like my mother,
like the things that
come outta my mouth
bother my mother so much.
- Really?
- [Kelly] So yeah, I'm just very open.
- Yeah.
- And she's not as much and so yeah,
she's like, "How did my
daughters come out of me?"
So I always wonder like how,
'cause we're both like me,
and I just always wonder like
what they do when they see on screen,
if they're just like this, or
if they're just fast forward,
if they're like skip in general.
- I didn't.
- She watches it.
I didn't tell her my boss
was (beep) The White Lotus.
(Kelly laughing)
I didn't tell her about-
- So like you didn't tell her,
and she found out that way?
Or like?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's just like, I wish I had a little bit
of a heads up but like, cute ass.
- [Kelly] Cute ass.
- Cute ass babe.
(Kelly laughing)
She's super supportive my mother.
- Your mum is so awesome.
- Would she ever preferred
for you to be pooping in the suitcase?
Or what ended up happening?
- That episode, that was so crazy.
- I think she was like, you know what?
You made your moment and you're either
gonna (bleep) in that suitcase
or show your ass and you did it.
You did it babe.
- Okay, no segue way there.